[Music]
so with this session what we'll do is
we'll talk through a little bit about
how we think we think about security at
Google and in G suite and then we will
show you some of the products that we
have that can remove some of that work
that you're having to do and then we
will spend some time in demos we'll
spend quite a bit of time in demos
because we think it's helpful to see how
these things work and then we'll finish
up by having one of our partners suma
logic talked about their experience in
integrating through our api's and kind
of how they are helping you automate
what you're doing as well so with that
security is increasingly difficult there
are more and more attacks and those
attacks are more and more sophisticated
so as administrators and security staff
it is something that is increasingly
difficult to protect your users devices
and data so with at G suite what we try
to do is we try to think through how we
can provide you the tools that you need
to really cover the different threats
that are coming at you and ensure that
you are the best protected against those
we've had the chance to have a lot of
conversations with our customers
partners and analysts and what we see is
kind of reoccurring themes there's a lot
of security tools out there that give
you a lot of data but at the same time
they fail to provide really actionable
valuable insights those that do provide
good insights many times lack the
controls and tools that you need to go
in and remediate those things and fix
them quickly and the solutions that do
manage to provide both of those to you
are many times very complex they require
specific expertise that are very hard to
find or a lot of training that takes a
lot of time and energy and money so what
we see is we see a lot of organizations
that have security tools that are
partially implemented and they're
planning on continuing to
meant those and finish them or they
finished the implementation but they're
just not sure how to effectively
leverage those tools so can if the
guiding principle that we are using at G
suite is how can we provide you a
comprehensive set of tools that is at
the same time simple and easy to use and
so we want to be we want to cover all of
your needs and all of the various
threats that are coming at you but at
the same time we want you to be able to
pick up those tools and start using them
and start finding value and so over the
last year you've seen a lot of launches
coming in security and these are just a
few of those things like automatic
enrollment in Google Management so
Google device management so when a user
comes in with a with BYOD and they sign
in with their corporate credentials it's
automatically enrolled for light
management and that allows you to see
what data those devices are accessing
and exactly what those devices are doing
and also allows you to wipe corporate
data from those devices security health
and the security dashboards which give
you a high-level overview of important
security metrics from your organization
the investigation tool which allows you
to dive and quickly get deep in the data
and take remediate of steps the alert
Center where we communicate the most
important things to you that you should
look into and proactively let you know
about things that are happening and then
of course Gmail and Gmail we know is a
huge vector of attack email in general I
should say so we are constantly
investing in Gmail to ensure that it is
very secure and covering all of your
needs and making sure that your users
are protected we've launched things like
security sandbox confidential mode and
business email compromised protections
and so we're consistently adding more
and more tools for you there so that
Gmail is the best possible solution for
you
however as we continue to talk to our
customers
one thing we consistently hear and I'm
sure you guys have heard this as well is
that there's always too much to do
there's always that one product or that
one vector of attack that you're trying
to get to that you just can't because
you have too much going on in other
areas we have yet to talk to a security
team that told us that they have too
much time on their hands or their two
fully staffed and we haven't seen that
yet if you do have that situation we'd
love to talk to you about how you got
there but with this what we're trying to
do is is find ways that we can help you
automate security and remove some of the
redundant tasks that you're doing now
that aren't really adding value or
aren't requiring all the expertise that
you have so that you can invest that
time and expertise into other areas that
will add more value to your organization
and so with that what we want to do is
we want to talk through just a couple of
products they're currently there that
are kind of removing work from you and
then we want to walk through a few new
products or enhancements to existing
products that will help you better
automate your workflows and then we'll
jump into some demos to show you how all
these things fit together so earlier I
mentioned Gmail now I really like this
image because I think it walks you
through kind of step by step what
protections are in place and whether
you're talking about before an email is
even sent or when a user receives it and
opens it and clicks on a link or even
grants third party o auth token you have
protections built in to help you better
protect each of those steps and remove
some of that kind of manual work that
you'd have to go in and investigate and
remediate these things so Gmail is an
area where you'll continue to see new
innovations and even this image doesn't
include everything because it doesn't
have security sandbox confidential mode
or business email compromised on their
so there's even more and honestly if we
put everything that GMOs doing on a
slide it would be much more than one
slide the second thing I want to hit on
again is the Google device management
and the automatic enrollment and this is
something that has had a really positive
impact for a lot of the organizations
that we work with
it gives them logging and visibility
into what is happening and all of those
logs are integrated into many of our
other security products like the
Security Center and so on top of having
visibility of what these devices are
doing you also have the option to wipe
that data so you don't have to go in and
manage those devices as much in the case
of BYOD devices and then hijacking
prevention is another area I want to
call out and specifically security keys
are a very very effective way to protect
your users and if you can prove if you
can prevent the hijackings it saves you
a ton of work that you have to do later
and cleaning them up and potential
damage or loss of company data so we
don't know of a single user that has
been compromised when they were using
security keys they're that effective and
we recommend that every user has them or
at least privileged users or using them
on top of the security keys though were
consistently investing in models to
detect anomalous behavior from users so
that we can find those and we can alert
you about them and so a lot of the
alerts that that you may have been
seeing in the alert Center are actually
generated automatically by identifying
anomalous behavior that users are doing
so with that I now want to talk about
kind of some of the newer betas and
launches that we have coming out to help
you automate your workflows the first is
work we've been doing around data loss
prevention or DLP and what we've been
doing is is working to unify the
experience of creating a gmail or Drive
rule so you can create one single rule
to automate automate the protection of
both of those products in addition we'll
talk through some of the other things
we've been doing around visibility to
help you better understand when those
rules are triggering and what they're
doing the second is the investigation
tool and we'll hit on the new activity
rules which allow you to build rules to
automate actions or alerts based on
specific events that are happening and
then the third is the alert center and
we'll talk about how we are making
updates and continuing to improve that
product so that you can see the most
relevant alerts first so we just want to
hit high-level on each of these and then
we'll show you kind of how they fit
together and how they work in the demo
flows and so first data loss prevention
if you're not familiar with the product
basically what it is is it's the ability
to create rules in Gmail and drive to
detect certain patterns whether that's
strings or regex
or using one of the predefined detectors
to block exfiltration before it happens
or also to detect malicious information
before it comes into your organization
one of the really cool things about data
loss prevention is it's built right into
the product so it stops things before
they happen so it's not something that
you know happens and then DLP goes and
cleans it up it actually prevents
documents from being shared in the first
place we'll show you a little bit more
about what that looks like but for the
updates for DLP what we've done is we've
unified the experience of creating these
rules but then also we've really
invested in logging and visibility
around what these rules are doing we've
gotten a lot of feedback that it would
make DLP much more effective when you
can see exactly when it triggers and
make sure that they are tailored to the
exact data you're trying to detect and
prevent from being shared and so we'll
walk you through how we've integrated
those logs and that visibility into the
security center and how you can use that
to look at other data and kind of figure
out what's happening with your sensitive
content
the second area is the security center
and so there's three major components to
the security center the first is
security help which keeps you up to date
on the newest tools and settings that
are available to you to best protect
your organization and so this is really
meant to help you be proactive and to
prevent issues before they even happen
the second is the security dashboards
which give you that high level overview
of important metrics in your
organization
these also give you actionable content
that you can find issues and then jump
quickly into the investigation tool to
act so they're meant to help you detect
issues and then the investigation tool
which allows you to do really advanced
queries to correlate data across
different types and then to take large
bulk actions and this tool is really
powerful because it scales from whether
you want to delete one you one email
from a user's inbox or whether you want
to delete a million so it scales really
well to the size of your organization so
with the security center one of the
things we're really excited about and
we've been doing a lot of work on the
security center in general but this
session will mainly focus on the new
activity rules and again these allow you
to based on any log query you do in the
investigation tool create automated
actions and alerts to let you know when
those things happen and so we'll show
you how powerful those can be in
remediating issues you've seen in the
past and they work great as a companion
to data loss prevention rules so with
that I want to welcome my colleague
darshan on the stage who will talk a
little bit more about the alert Center
and some of the changes we've been doing
there Thank You Chad my name is darshan
patel and i'm one of the product
managers within G suite that works on
alert Center and first of all I'm super
excited to be here to tell you about the
new beta features that were launching in
the alert Center that has launched as of
this morning
but first a little bit of a summary
about the alert Center the alert Center
launched about six months ago and it's
available for all G suite licenses so
that includes basic biz
and enterprise and it really provides
three key capabilities it provides a
single pane of glass of all your
essential security notifications so this
makes you makes it easier for you to
save time with everything in one place
it also gives you a view of your overall
security exposure to help you prioritize
your team's workload as well as making
it easy and faster to do remediation
with integration into other tools the
alerts Center has several different
types of alerts across three primary
categories the first category is
phishing and Malware as Chad talked
about that is one of the most common
threats that we see and his slide
earlier showed about 91% of cyber
security starts in email so this is the
area that we continuously invest in so
we showed that 99.9% of spam and
phishing emails get stopped before they
make it to the user but users attacked
attacks keep changing over time and we
keep learning as we learn we go back and
see if any of the messages inside your
users inboxes have been affected and
matched new patterns we've learned about
and this is what we call
reclassification when this occurs we
will automatically move the emails from
your users inboxes and put them into the
spam account for you and if your users
had already engaged with those messages
you will get a notification in the alert
Center to let you know that there's
something that you should go investigate
and then you can move it or delete it
for your user the second category is
account warnings and this is where we're
using machine learning models to detect
suspicious behavior that might be
occurring in that account and this is
looking for compromised accounts that
might have been occurred during login or
even during in-app activity in the third
area is device management that Chad also
touched upon and here were automatically
looking at suspicious device behavior so
if a device has been rooted or it's
jailbroken or device properties have
changed
that device and one of the the key goals
of the alert Center for us is to help
you protect your users your devices and
your data now listening to our customers
is one of the most important things we
do and it helps us make a good product
even better we talked about a hundred or
several hundred customers where we
received feedback through surveys
interviews and our alpha program and I'd
like to thank all those alpha customers
several are here today for their
participation giving us feedback across
the whole G suite family of security
products one of the common themes that
we heard was the need for collaboration
and this was to make it easier for teams
to prioritize their workloads so with
today's beta release we focused on these
areas the first one is being able to
help you prioritize automatically by
giving each alert type a different
severity setting so Google has gone
ahead and mapped the severity to each of
the alerts but you as your admin you can
change those to fit your business needs
the second is the ability to track
status so you can now see if alerts are
new in progress or closed and the third
is to manage workloads by assigning
alerts to different team members so this
enables faster prioritization and more
efficient collaboration so now let's
take a look at a demo so let me quickly
log in and the first time I'm going to
show you is how easy it is to roll into
mobile device management for your users
there we go all right so let me go to
mobile device management so I'm gonna
click on the menu on the upper left hand
corner hit devices and go to mobile
devices and on my let me login to my
admin account and on my device I'm going
ahead and just logging into my corporate
email account so I just need to do a
couple clicks here so just like any user
and when the login and here I just need
to agree to the Terms of Service and
it's gonna check against the device
policies that you've set up as an admin
and I just need to agree to enroll so
let me do that and now here in the admin
console you will see that there are
about ten devices and this is all live
I'm going to go ahead and refresh and
let's see if we see the new device
enrolled so perfect we see good darshan
pixel to excel that has just enrolled
and now you have the ability to manage
this device and this device is following
the policies that you have already set
if you wanted you can click on the three
men you on the end and you can see some
of the features like wipe the device or
delete the device available so that is
showing you just how easy it is for
users to automatically enroll and be
protected on the device front next we're
gonna go into the alerts center so I'm
going to click on that same menu and go
to security and alerts enter and here
you can see there's several email or
several alerts that you have the admins
can see and we're gonna pick the one
that's device compromised so let me open
that one up and now in this journey
we're gonna go through and see how easy
it is to triage messages and prioritize
them so we can see that this Android
device was routed and there belongs to
darshan at dynamic 70 that happens to be
the device I had just in
rolled and there's different device
properties there and as we scroll down
we can see this new section called
related alerts so this is one of the new
beta features that we just launched this
week and what we're doing here is we're
looking for other alerts within the
alert center that might have to do with
this incident to help you triage it
better so the first one here is the
phishing message detected post delivery
so this looks pretty interesting this is
one of the examples we had talked about
earlier so let me click on that and I
can see Google has detected one
reclassified message from darshan at my
big are name so that looks pretty
suspicious so let's go back to the other
message now we know that we have a story
coming together looking at the next
related alert I can see that as leaked
password so this is another detection we
do automatically on your behalf we are
looking at public sites where your users
credentials have been leaked and when we
find those situations we automatically
notify you through the alert Center so
you can work with your users to remedy
that situation another alert is
government backed attacks so again we
are automatically detecting if there
might be a state-sponsored initiative
that is trying to compromise your users
so it looks like there's a lot of
serious situations going on here so let
me scroll back up to the top and
prioritize and assign this alerts so I'm
gonna change the severity to high
because there's a lot going on here I'm
gonna change the status to in progress
and assign it to my colleague Chad and
it automatically pre-fills and let me
apply that
so again just within a few minutes we
were able to show how easy it is to
triage and prioritize and alert next
let's go back to the alerts center
screen and we're gonna pretend that now
I'm Chad just a little shorter and go
back in here and I see that there's an
alert assigned to me we would have also
sent an email to Chad say
that darshan at Dyna or darshan the
admin had sent or unassigned him an
alert so I'm gonna open this up and you
can see in the upper right hand corner
all these fields are there again these
are all part of the new beta and if I
scroll to the bottom in the alert
history area you can see a change log of
everything that has happened with this
account so teams can collaborate better
and know what has happened so let me go
back up to the top and this is where we
have the integrated remediation so as an
admin I could go one of a couple of
different ways one I might try to figure
out how this happened and we did have
some leads there through the phishing
and leaked a password alerts and the
other one might be to see are there any
other things that might have happened
such as data exfiltration maybe sharing
of drive documents so let's go and click
on the investigate alert and this is
part of the seamless integration and now
I'm going to open up the investigation
tool and in the investigation tool it is
pre filling the characteristics from the
alert into the query builder so you
don't have to do any of that and if I
scroll to the bottom you can see there's
that result for the compromised device
now I'm going to pivot to see if there
might have been any data exfiltration
that occurred in Drive so by the device
owner I'm gonna click on the three dots
menu and you'll see a whole list of
items let me scroll down a little bit
different ways you can pivot on this
information and I'm gonna select drive
logs actor and this is to look where
darshan at dynamic 70 had done Drive log
events or used drive and I'm going to
add a condition here to see if I the
visibility has been changed and in
particular we're looking to see if the
visibility change let me pick that
condition has changed externally so
we're gonna look to see if anything went
from internal to external and I'll
scroll down and click on search
he usually just takes a few seconds all
right as I scroll down we will see that
there's six documents that have changed
in endurance account that have gone from
internal to external and looking at the
titles they look pretty sensitive we see
ordered charts for a secret project M&A
activity PR DS sales projections so
let's go ahead and click on the checkbox
to select all of them and look at what
actions we can perform so here we can
change the owners remove users disable
download copy print as well as go little
deeper we'll file to audit profile
permissions so let's go ahead and click
on that and now it's gonna open up a new
window where you can see more details on
exactly who documents have been shared
with in this case we can see the project
zero org chart has been shared mainly
with internal employees at dynamic 70
but we also see there is one external
person of bad darshan at my big our name
and this one if you may recall happen to
be the same related alert that was
responsible for the phishing email so
let me go ahead and revoke privileges by
clicking on the menu and I can remove
access for bad darshan but we also want
to look at all the documents so let me
click on the left side to select all the
documents and I can click on actions and
I can go ahead and select which users I
want to remove and I'm going to remove
darshan that my bigger name and now he
has been removed from access for all of
these files while we're on this screen
we should also go and check to see if
any documents might have been shared
publicly so I'm clicking on links up at
the top and I can see three of the
documents have been made public so let's
go ahead and click on the title select
all of those and edit the link sharing
and let's make these all restricted and
I'm gonna go ahead and
by that alright so just within a few
minutes we were able to go through three
common security use cases where we can
show how we helped automate and simplify
the experience the first one was
automatic enrollment into mobile device
management the second one was
automatically looking for incidents and
suspicious behaviors that are occurring
for your users this case was the device
being compromised we also saw a leaked
pack password and a post delivery of
phishing reclassification as well as how
easy it is to triage investigate and
remediate a situation with that I'm
going to hand it back over to Chad to
continue on with the demo
[Applause]
okay so darshan walked us through how
you can use the alert Center to better
understand the threats that are coming
into our organization and then how you
can quickly use those to remediating
issues I want to talk a little bit about
how we can use policy to prevent issues
from happening and then also after we've
done an investigation similar to what
darshan showed you how we can set a
activity rule to prevent that type of
thing from happening again
or at least automate alerts around those
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to start with the new data loss
prevention experience and so if you come
to the left-hand menu and you go to
security and you look under data
protection this is kind of the beta
experience so if you sign up for the
beta for DLP this is what you'd see so
here we can click on manage rules and we
have a list of rules we've created and
in this specific scenario we have a rule
we created around Project utopia which
is a sensitive project that this company
this organization is working on and so
what they've done is they've gone
through and they've created a policy for
the entire organization when a file was
shared
or we could do also when an email is
sent if it contains utopia we want to
block external sharing and so we've
created this rule and now if we go to
Drive we can find a file related to
utopia here
so if we open something related to
utopia what we see as an end user is it
actually changes the way that the
sharing icon looks so it shows a shield
showing that this document is actually
sensitive it should not be shared
externally if the user hovers over the
sharing icon it also informs them of
that and this is really important
because it is educating the end users
it's helping them understand what types
of content are sensitive and what they
should be thinking about when they're
looking at documents like this if they
do decide to go ahead and continue and
try to share this document when they go
to share it to anyone on the web what
will happen is they'll actually receive
an error which will tell them that this
is sensitive they cannot share it
externally beyond just educating the end
user though we know that it's really
important for admins to have visibility
into how their policies are interacting
with content and exactly what's
happening so one of the other things
that you'll see in the beta experience
for DLP is you'll see this investigate
rule option and this is similar to what
darshan was showing you in the alert
Center but when you click on this what
happens is it takes you into the
investigation tool and it queries for
that specific rule which will show you
all the logs associated with it for when
that rule has triggered so we can see
that specifically this rule has
triggered on quite a few different
documents related to utopia so the road
map the financials the competitive
analysis and it looks like it's all been
done by this chad tyler user so there
might be something going on with this
user we can dig in deeper and actually
figure out what's happening so we can
dig in and remediate this specific issue
so we'll pivot on this user and we'll
look at Gmail log events where this user
received the email and we'll say
specifically we want to see emails that
are not from our current organization so
we'll copy that and also we want to
filter out emails that are from Google
in that we don't want to see the alerts
that are coming in and then when we
query for that what this will show us is
the external emails that this user
received so we want to see potentially
how this user was compromised by a
phishing email so we see several
different emails that came in
specifically we can look at the log
events for what happened it looks like
this user only opened and clicked on one
email so you can see here the updated
Terms of Service they received it they
opened it and then they quick Don a link
and it looks like it went to a malicious
site so we know that this might be
potentially how they were compromised
now what we can do here is we can
actually pivot on this message ID and we
can see everyone in our organization who
received this and so we'll look for
everyone in our organization who
received this specific email to make
sure that no one else was compromised
and so we can see here quite a few of
our users received it but this user was
the only one that opened it and the only
one that clicked on the link just to
make sure that there's no more issues
with this email we can come and we can
delete these messages to make sure that
none of our other users click on this so
we'll type that in and we can click
delete so now what we can do is we can
actually we've we've come in we've
created the DLP rule we've looked at
kind of where that's triggered and then
we've gone to better understand like how
that user was compromised in the first
place but it looks like this domain Inc
42 com is targeting our users so we
might want to actually prevent this from
happening again in the future and so
what I want to show you now is how you
can use activity rules the new activity
rules that we've added to the
investigate
a tool to create policies based on the
attributes of logs that you're receiving
so we'll create a new query and we'll
say Gmail log events if it's from and it
contains ink 42 we want to block it and
so we'll say specifically when we
receive emails from ink 42 and then what
we can do right within the investigation
tool is we can come to this read menu
and we can go to create rule and that
takes us to a pretty similar experience
to what you saw for data loss prevention
or DLP and we can say block bad domain
and then this pulls in the query that we
were using in the investigation tool
itself and then when we go to the next
step
this will generate a preview for us for
how often emails from Inc 42 have come
into our organization so you can kind of
see the history of when that's happened
and then we can say if within an hour it
happens even zero times or if we want to
set a specific threshold we can say more
than 100 or more than a thousand so this
works really well for things like
document exfiltration if you want to see
if more than a certain amount of
documents are shared outside of your
organization and this is a really
flexible tool that you can use then we
can set an action and say if we receive
an email from Inc 42 I want to send it
to quarantine or I want to delete it
whatever makes sense and then we also
want to receive an alert and I want to
send that alert to the admin and so just
that quickly we can create a new rule
which will then perform that action
whenever our threshold is triggered and
it will also send us on alert and you'll
receive that alert in the same alert
center that darshan was walking you
through before and so that's a quick
view of how you can use data loss
prevention to prevent things from before
they even happen how you can use the
logs associate
with those to dig in detect and
remediate issues and then how you can go
back to prevention you can use the
activity rules within the investigation
tool to use the same queries you were
using to prevent this from happening
again and kind of follow that loop of
continuing to tailor your organization
so that you have less of these things
happening and you can prevent them from
from happening in the first place so
with that we want to jump back to the
slides really quick and I want to hit on
AP eyes so ap eyes are obviously a
really important part of automating
security and so all of the data that we
just showed you is available through
these three different api's and so the
product api is themselves you you use
the Gmail drive device management API s
and you can get a state information that
we were showing you the reports API is
where all of the logs are available and
then the alert center API allows you to
pull all the alerts into other tools if
you're using other tools to manage your
alerts and to coordinate your
remediation and so we know that alert
that the api's are a very important part
of this story one of the things that we
wanted to do is show you how one of our
partners was able to leverage these
api's to build a product that allows you
to get better visibility and automate
remediation as well and we also know
that it's very important to be able to
extend this to your broader ecosystem
which is why we wanted to bring reishi
from sumo logic to talk a little bit
more about their experience in building
out a product based on these api's
regime
Thank You Chan so my name is Rishi dev
day I'm the product manager for apps and
integrations at Summa logic and I want
to thank Google for giving us this
opportunity to partner with them and
allowing us to showcase our integration
with G suite and alert Center so a
little bit about sumo logic we are a
cloud native machine data analytics
service and we support over 2000
customers across various industry
verticals some of our key customers are
Airbnb Major League Baseball
New York Life visa and salesforce.com so
Summa logic helps in three major areas
the first being operational analytics
where we help you monitor alert and
troubleshoot your application issues or
performance the second area is business
analytics where we help you understand
how customers are using your
applications and finally security
analytics which is the focus of today's
presentation where we help you monitor
detect investigate and respond to
security alerts and threats
so Summa logic provides these
capabilities in one platform so you get
the data in once and you get operational
business and security insights so how
does this work so we collect index and
store machine data which includes events
logs and metrics from a number of
on-premise SAS and cloud platform data
sources once this data is in you can
query it with our rich query language
dashboards or use out-of-the-box
applications so one of these apps is the
Summa logic G suite app we have over a
hundred customers using this app across
the globe and it's focused on three
major UK use cases
the first being G suite usage and then
administrative activity and security
monitoring so over the past few months
we've been working with the alert Center
team towards collecting and analyzing
alerts enter data so combining alerts
enter data with G suite activity logs
that we are already collecting and data
from other applications and security
data sources we see sumo logic and
Google
providing three key benefits the first
being the ability to monitor and detect
critical security threats by combining
alerts from alert center with alerts
from other security data sources
secondly investigating and correlating
alerts with G suite activity and other
applications this is so you can
determine the root cause and effects of
your alerts and finally responding and
remediating alerts when they occur again
so to summarize how this works we
collect data from G suite via the
reports API and from alert Center we are
the alert sender API so these are the
api's that Chad just talked about and I
just wanted to comment the G suite team
for making this critical data available
and as we will see going forward this
helps our customers quickly investigate
and respond to alerts in their IT
infrastructure so once this data comes
in we have rich out-of-the-box
dashboards that analyze both G suite
activity and data from alerts Center so
let's take a look at an example of how
sumo logic can help monitor detect and
investigate threats so this is our G
suite overview dashboard that shows a
summary of all the activity that's
happening in G suite and we have drill
downs specific to a large Center this
shows our alert Center overview
dashboard that shows all the data that
we've gotten from alert Center so far so
here we see an example of a user's
credentials being compromised and I just
want to point out the level of detail
that's coming in from alert Center where
you have the username the time this
compromised happened and the alert type
and this is something that you
definitely want to go ahead and
investigate so this brings us to the
alert Center Investigations dashboard in
sumo logic where we've automatically
correlated alert Center data with all of
GCL activity and we have this these two
panels that shows all G suite activities
by compromised users similarly you also
want to look into all the logins by
compromised users to
how active they are and where they're
coming from okay this kind of ability
where we focus our panels on all
activities and logins by compromised
users we also have panels for
compromised devices we've seen helps
analysts security analysts and security
teams cut down the amount of time
required to investigate and alert our
incidentally so we've talked about
correlating alerts and data with G speed
activity but what about your other
business applications right so here we
we are seeing an example on the right
where we are doing a search in sumo
logic across all of salesforce.com
event data to get a list of all the
reports downloaded by a compromised user
that was detected by alert center so
having this capability of investigating
data across various applications is
something that is super valuable for our
customers and that's why they use us for
their security use cases so I also
wanted to point out that you can easily
create your own dashboards in sumo logic
by combining dashboard panels from
various apps or even creating some of
your own so by doing this you can create
a dashboard that's very specific to your
company or organization and you get a
quick overview of all the security
aspects whether it's endpoints network
identity management systems cloud
platforms or even on-premise data
sources so now that we've looked into
how to monitor detect and investigate
security alerts let's talk about how to
automatically remediate these when they
happen again so this is a document from
the G suite help that talks about how to
identify and secure compromised G suite
accounts so this is a like a four-step
process and this is an example of a
workflow and creating managing and
creating and managing these workflows in
a consistent manner is critical for
maintaining your overall security
posture so what we assumed illogic do
help in automate the creation of these
incident response workflows by sending
data to a number of ticketing
notification and response systems we
also see that this kind of workflow
creation and sending critical data about
what happened helps in reducing the time
to investigate by providing context
around an alert or incident so for
example listing out all the activities
that happen by a particular compromised
user finally creating these workflows is
also something that we've seen that
helps prevent alert fatigue by sending
data to the to the right teams that have
specific areas of responsibility as
opposed to sending all alerts to the
entire security team so just to
summarize our experience as a partner
we've seen how G suite and alert Center
have given us critical data to further
enable our customers to monitor detect
investigate and respond to security
alerts and threats with that I'd like to
call the shine back on stage to
summarize our talk Thank You Rishi a
really Prius a great appreciate the
great overview how Google and sumo logic
can work together to provide integrated
solutions that fit well into your
existing infrastructure to summarize
what we covered today the first one was
which hadn't been talking about about
some of the pain points that many of you
face too much data
lack of insights lack of control as well
as complexity with existing solutions so
we covered three ways one is through
hijacking protection with security keys
another one is device management as well
as phishing protection as well we
covered three of the new betas that
we're launching this week first one was
allert Center that now provides built-in
collaboration to help you prioritize
your alert management the second one was
DLP to provide you capabilities to
prevent sense
data transfer and the third was activity
rules that now helps you automate
repetitive tasks as well as to apply
automatic actions and alerts also we
want to thank sumo logic for being here
to talk about how we're collaborating
with our partner ecosystem to build
solutions that integrate within your
existing infrastructure with that I'd
like to thank all of you for attending
today at the bottom there is a blog that
we just published this morning that has
the link to all of the beta signup forms
for the three that we talked about today
and we're gonna stay around afterwards
to answer any questions we'll be upfront
and then in the hallway afterwards thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]